bonjour 12e numéro du café politique sur
téléfil 78 bonjour et bienvenue au
bistrot du théâtre à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Benoît Hamon
bienvenue vous êtes député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines députés
socialistes ancien ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire ancien
ministre de l'Éducation et conseiller
municipale également à Trappes on
enregistre cette émission à quelques
jours du congrès de Poitiers congrès
socialiste qui va permettre d'enterrer
la ligne directrice du parti vous en
attendez quoi concrètement de ce
rendez-vous vous qui jusqu'à présent
vous êtes montré plutôt critique sur ce
qui a été fait par le gouvernement
depuis trois ans
bon j'ai été critique sur certains
aspects surtout j'étais ministre
le point sur lequel je reste
réservé ce sont les politiques
économiques et sociales en clair on a
on le voit ici sur ce territoire mais
ailleurs des Français qui ont toujours
des problèmes de pouvoir d'achat
des problèmes de la vie quotidienne qui
restent importants d'emploi de
souffrance au travail etc et ce qu'on
attend de la gauche
droite ou gauche quand la gauche arrive
au pouvoir c'est qu'il y ait davantage
de justice sociale je pense que sur
cette aspect là
faut qu'on exploite les deux ans qui
viennent totalement sur ce terrain là
que moi j'attendais modifications et
j'espère que le Congrès de Poitiers
pour les différentes motions soutenez la
motion la motion B qui fait 30 % un
petit peu moins de 30 %
déjà c'est une première c'est une
déception c'est suffisant 30 % 47 dans
les Yvelines effectivement mais c'est un
petit peu l'anomalie par rapport à même
à la région francilienne puisque votre
motion est arrivée en tête mais vous
êtes implanté ici ça peut paraître tout
de même assez logique au-delà de ça
c'est 29% au niveau national est-ce que
c'est une réflexion est-ce que ça va
permettre une infection
pourquoi on voter sur des orientations
que faire en gros des deux ans qui
viennent et ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
le texte
consignait tous les ministres d'un texte
qui dit ou revendique la nécessité d'un
changement de cap sur certains de
questions économiques ou de questions
sociales donc maintenant
moi ce que je vais regarder avec
attention c'est si ces engagements pris
et qui ont permis à ce texte majoritaire
devant les militants seront tenus député
avec une action nationale action locale
aussi vous êtes conseiller municipal à
Trappes je le rappelais tout à l'heure
nous sommes allés dans votre ville
demander ce que les habitants pensez de
vous quelle imagine vous avez vous
plutôt
positifs qui vient au Conseil Municipal
après son activité locale connaît pas
la sympathie pour lui c'est certain dans
le type bien qui consciencieux
qui inspire confiance enfin moi il
m'inspire confiance j'étais très déçu
d'un gouvernement se tape et puis on
accepte Singapour il a des idées un peu
un peu tranchées mais c'est normal en
politique il peut m'inspirer confiance
les mêmes idées surtout les sujets que
lui il a même pas été capable côté
ministre de faire
quelque chose pour le cabinet médical il
a fallu que les habitants se mobilisent
c'est qu'il faut une pétition et ça a
été pris par le Parti communiste où
était Monsieur Benoît hameau voilà
Monsieur Benoît Hamon ne fait rien pour
trap tu vois que sa place plus haut
ministre ou autre chose
pour réagir sur cette cette dernière
personne moi je peux pas reprocher aux
électeurs de pas pouvoir la réalité de
ce qu'on fait quand on
négocie des centaines de milliers
d'euros de crédit qui auraient disparu
notamment je prends un exemple à raison
justement des politiques budgétaires qui
aujourd'hui sert les vis et serre les
boulons il devait y avoir à peu près 150
000 euros de crédit de réussite
éducative en moins pour trap ça veut
dire que des programmes d'accompagnement
des enfants qui sont absolument
indispensables pour qu'ils puissent ne
pas perdre le fil et abandonner en route
et bien c'est 150000 euros la ministre
c'était vendredi dernier a annoncé
qu'elle les rétablirait mais je vais
aller même plus loin
la couverture de la N10 sujet qui est
débattu depuis des années
sur mesure de dire que non seulement
aujourd'hui on est en train de boucler
les études mais qui ont enfin l'enquête
publique va pouvoir commencer et qu'on
peut aujourd'hui parce que nous avons
fait inscrire 110 millions d'euros au
contrats région là c'est du tangible
c'est du signé la politique pour vous
débute à 19 ans vous êtes né en 67
engagement militant lors d'une
manifestation organisée contre le projet
de réforme de l'université de vaquet le
ministre de Jacques Chirac à l'époque
c'est ça le déclenchement de
l'engagement politique pour vous ça
remonte à ça
les premiers
avant en tout cas la conscience
politique c'est quelque chose d'assez
sommaire un peu rudimentaire au départ
mais quand on est quand on a 16-17 ans
mais j'étais très heurté par le racisme
pas pourquoi parce que j'ai fait une
partie de ma scolarité comme en font en
Afrique noire et où on était là
évidemment des écoles très mélangées par
définition
peu de repères et quand je suis rentré
en France il y avait été très frappé par
en Bretagne qui n'était pas une spéciale
moi une région raciste mais il y avait
du racisme et c'est ça qui m'a
qui a été le moteur de mon engagement je
ne supportais assez mal
les manifestations d'intolérance en
direction de gens juste en raison de
leur couleur de peau elle est partie
socialiste ça s'est imposé justement
dans cette
c'était parti de gauche qui était là qui
était disponible vous savez beaucoup de
hasard au sens où vous rencontrez des
personnes moi j'ai pas été trop de ski
dans la jeunesse par exemple d'ailleurs
le point dit que j'étais trop de ski
c'est bien une chose que j'ai pas été
Michel Rocard un homme qui a été
influent pour vous vous avez été
fondateur du Mouvement des Jeunes
Socialistes et c'est Michel Rocard qui a
donné un petit peu dépendance
l'autonomie à cette à cette formation
c'est surprenant Michel Rocard c'est
plutôt libéral c'est pas la cause de la
gauche
grossièrement quand on dit le PS il est
Mitterrand à la gauche on leur a dit et
regarde la droite la réalité c'est que
quand vous regardez et vous quand on lit
quand on prend le temps de lire Michel
Rocard on vote par exemple dans la
critique qu'il a de la financiarisation
de l'économie
d'un développement d'une forme de
capitalisme dévoyé etc qui se
désintéresse finalement de l'outil
industriel pour se préoccuper que de la
rentabilité de l'action et du capital il
a eu un discours très fort et des
propositions qui ont été très
importantes et quand on voit la place
qu'il a accordé lui à la question par
exemple climatique il a un des premiers
socialistes à cette emparé de cette
question là où honnêtement on a été nous
ma gauche très en retard de ce qui était
les prises de conscience dans la société
civile ou du côté d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts par exemple de l'importance
aujourd'hui de de du climat et de
l'environnement et pourquoi est-ce que
c'est important d'ailleurs parce que
quand l'environnement se dégrade ça
touche qui au premier les catégories les
plus vulnérables et les plus modestes et
c'est pour ça que l'on joue
environnemental c'est aussi un enjeu
social bien sûr ces questions là
rocaroïne ça a été une ça reste une
référence mais pour la gauche même pour
ceux qui
bien sûr je n'ai pas envie depuis
longtemps pour être très honnête tu dois
recroiser l'année dernière
et ça reste une référence
intellectuelle que je respecte et avec
laquelle je conserve des points d'accord
évidemment pour rester dans cette
classification parce qu'il y a tout de
même des tendances au sein du Parti
socialiste comme dans tous les partis
mais plutôt à gauche de la gauche ça
c'est fait à quel moment à quel moment
vous avez forgé vos idées mais j'ai
l'impression que je voulais dire que
j'ai pas bougé mais que c'est le PS qui
a bougé vers la droite oui c'est ça au
fond mon sentiment c'est ça c'est que
j'ai l'impression
moi je reste fidèle une somme de
conviction ce qui veut pas dire que on
doit pas les réévaluer à l'aune de la
modernité on n'est pas socialiste de la
même manière on propose pas les mêmes
choses au 21e siècle au 20e siècle mais
la question sur les valeurs et les
principes et la façon dont on voulait
transformer en solution derrière Benoît
Mo invité du café politique on va passer
à la seconde partie de ce rendez-vous en
parler de l'actualité nationale et puis
locale aussi avec vous
seconde partie du café politique les
élus qui viennent ici et parler de leur
parcours parler également de leur
actualité Benoît Monteils national tout
d'abord votre activité c'est ce texte
que vous portez à l'assemblée des
amendements plus précisément sur le
projet de dialogue social et c'est sur
le burn out professionnel il y a un de
des amendements qui prévoyaient que les
affections psychiques soient reconnus
comme maladie professionnelle je parle
au passé parce qu'il y a une partie de
ses amendements qui ont été refusés
notamment
il y a des abonnements qui sont refusés
pas parce que le gouvernement les refuse
parce qu'ils sont jugés irrecevables par
ce qu'on appelle
très clair c'est parce que ça
augmenterait les budgets les dépenses
qui est très stérilisant pour l'activité
des parlementaires puisque ça n'empêche
d'amander les textes comme on le
souhaiterait et deux amendements qui ont
été acceptés par le gouvernement qui
vont ouvrir la reconnaissance du burn
out comme une maladie professionnelle ça
touche à peu près 3 de salariés en
France en tout cas on risque et
l'objectif qui est le mien c'est que
plutôt que de se retrouver aujourd'hui à
ce que c'est maladie soit prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie et
qu'elle le soit par la branche accident
du travail maladie professionnelle qui
est financé par les entreprises pourquoi
pour qu'elle se ces entreprises soient
incitée à modifier leur organisation du
travail de façon à ce qu'elle n'est pas
payée pour ses burn out mais ça concerne
tout le monde le burn out ça va de
l'agriculture au fonctionnaires c'est le
public et le privé vous ciblez plus
particulièrement les entreprises vous
dites les agriculteurs l'agriculteurs
qui est tout seul dans son exploitation
avec d'autres personnes mais demain il
pourra faire reconnaître sa maladie
c'est aussi extrêmement important pour
tout le monde il y a eu un peu plus de
200 cas de Burn Out reconnus comme
maladie professionnelle en France
l'année dernière 11000 en Belgique alors
il y a une hypothèse c'est qu'en
Belgique qui soit plus stressée que les
Français il y en a une autre c'est
considéré qu'en France on reconnaît pas
comme on le devrait le burn out c'est ce
qui me semble être la bonne option pour
ça que je suis très heureux que le
gouvernement est accepté mes amendements
mais une partie mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai un mais j'entends aller évidemment
plus loin on parle globalement des
entreprises on va élargir un peu parler
d'économie au cours de cette émission ce
sont des élus d'autres bords politiques
donc de l'UMP nous sommes allés voir
pour vous pour qu'il vous interpelle
qu'il vous pose directement des
questions Jean-Michel fourousse l'ancien
député de la 11e circonscription et qui
vous interpelle il souhaite vous
entendre sur les résultats du
gouvernement
ma première question c'est sur le plan
économique d'abord monsieur Hamon
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce tableau
ça c'est la dernière année où en fait la
droite
vous avez un set de croissance et puis
dès que vous prenez le pouvoir voilà
vous prenez des mesures qui cassent la
croissance donc ma question c'est est-ce
que vous rendez compte du drame que l'on
vit que nos entreprises vivent vous
aviez premier un million d'emplois
toutes catégorie en fait au bout de
trois ans on a une destruction de plus
d'un million d'emplois toute catégories
environ 600 000 de catégories mais plus
d'un million de catégories donc vous
aviez promis également de baisser les
impôts notamment la TVA qui est le
premier impôt des Français vous avez
augmenté vous augmentez près de 50
milliards l'ensemble des impôts donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette de ce
de cette façon de faire de la politique
de se faire élire en mentant
délibérément enfin en présentant des
choses qui sont qui sont totalement IR
artiste qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ce
pays la France qui voilà à ce discours
politique complètement coupé des
réalités les discours politique du
gouvernement de l'action du gouvernement
coupée de la réalité l'économiste
stoppée par le l'action des socialistes
d'abord pas vous dire que la croissance
est là elle est pas là
et Monsieur Hollande puisque les
millions de millions d'emplois c'est
Monsieur Gattaz qu'il a promis en
contrepartie des 40 et 1 milliard
d'euros distribués aux entreprises que
la gauche fait que la droite n'avait
jamais fait d'ailleurs qui fait partie
de moi des reproches que je fais c'est
que je pense que faut pas distribuer
l'argent sans qu'il y ait de
contrepartie et donc les contreparties
c'était le million d'emplois
effectivement ce million d'emplois on
l'attend encore ce qu'il a démonstration
de quoi c'est que il faut pouvoir
soutenir aujourd'hui la capacité des
entreprises à restaurer leur marge mais
dans les secteurs où elles en ont besoin
sauf à ce que l'argent public quand il
va ces entreprises soit distribuées sous
forme de dividendes ni à
l'investissement ni à l'augmentation des
salaires moi ma conviction et je crois
illustré par les faits ce qui m'amène à
avoir un débat avec le gouvernement je
suis pas béni oui-oui d'ailleurs
peut-être à la différence de quelques
autres et on peut m'en faire le reproche
y compris dans mon propre camp je crois
que
c'est ma conviction profonde si nous ne
soutenons pas le pouvoir d'achat ce que
nous avons fait pour les entreprises
sera totalement vain nous sommes
d'accord avec ce que dit Jean-Michel
forest le gouvernement je pense qu'il a
échoué aussi
je vous dis qu'il a réussi quand il le
chômage a augmenté
soit je suis fou ou alors je suis de
très mauvaise foi pour jusqu'ici il n'y
a pas les résultats j'espère qu'ils vont
venir et je ne me réjouis pas qu'il
n'existe pas mais ces résultats mais je
suis pas dans j'essaye de ne pas être
dans les postures justement
un peu grossière et idéologique je
prétends faire la leçon à personne mais
en économie surtout quand j'ai pas eu de
résultats moi-même c'était le cas de
Monsieur fourgouse donc voilà mais bon
oui il y aura une bonne manière
d'enrichir la casquisse c'est que si on
demandait à Monsieur fauguste de mettre
à chaque fois un euro dans une cagnotte
chaque fois qu'il cite Benoît Hamon je
pense que je pourrais rééquilibrer le
budget de la casquille inverser un héros
supplémentaire il a encore une question
à vous poser ça concerne les rythmes
scolaires
deuxièmement
une question je dirais plus sur
également le parler vrai sur les rythmes
scolaires cette fameuse réforme
et bien écoute 2 milliards d'abord donc
qui va payer comment les communes
aujourd'hui qui perdent leur dotation de
l'État comment elles peuvent payer une
réforme qui est aussi
inefficace et qui coûte aussi cher ne
serait-ce qu'attrape dans votre commune
vous aviez promis vous disiez 150 euros
par enfant le coût en fait même votre
propre premier adjointe à l'éducation
madame Marie dit que c'est pas 150 euros
c'est 400 euros par enfant est-ce que
vous imaginez l'erreur et comment les
communes vont bien sûr payer cela mise
en place difficile sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires Jean-Michel fourgouse
qui évoquera pas en ce moment il y a
encore une réflexion pour réorganiser
les horaires parce que il manque des
animateurs et ça coûte cher et qu'il
faut trouver le meilleur ajustement
possible absolument alors deux mots
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait la réforme
des rythmes scolaires pourquoi est-ce
qu'on rajoute un matin de plus
parce qu'au départ c'est ça c'est pas
les activités périscolaires je vais en
dire un mot parce que c'est un sujet
important et je veux pas esquiver la
question de Jean-Michel fourmousse y
compris les contre-vérités mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on rajoute une matinée de plus
parce que le niveau baisse aujourd'hui
dans l'école et qu'on sait que les
enfants apprennent mieux le matin après
la conséquence de ce matin de plus c'est
quoi c'est qu'effectivement on va
libérer du temps et on a souhaité que ce
temps là plutôt que d'être utilisé à des
garderies comme c'est le cas et
l'encours ce soit utilisé à des
activités périscolaires j'observe ce
fourgon de le dire que il y a un fond
qui a été mis en place qui donne 50
euros par enfant ce qui est pas
suffisant mais quand on fait que des
garderies
à quoi sert cet argent moi je considère
que cette réforme elle se déploie c'est
logique que chaque année on réévalu le
contenu des activités périscolaires
parce qu'ils vont s'améliorer c'est
notre contenu des activités
périscolaires mais ce qui est important
c'est d'évaluer dans quelques années ce
qui aura été l'impact sur le niveau de
vos enfants des enfants du territoire de
cette matinée de plus on va parler de la
reconquête également reconquête de la
gauche sur le département des Yvelines
parce qu'aujourd'hui au lendemain
il y a plus d'agglomération le
département uniquement détenu par le
Centre par la droite également il vous
reste quelques postes de députés mais
notamment avec le vôtre mais la droite
est fortement augmentée tout à fait la
droite est fortement implantée dans le
département comment vous allez réussir à
reconquérir et notamment dans l'optique
des régionales qui vont se dérouler à la
fin de l'année
il va y avoir déjà il faut prendre les
élections les unes après les autres mais
je pense que
il y a un travail de renouvellement que
le Parti socialiste doit poursuivre de
ces équipes des visages qu'il représente
mais ça ne tient pas qu'à ça c'est aussi
à la crédibilité de ce qu'on dit
quand vous avez des électeurs qui
pensent alors
que le discours politique c'est du
baratin
je fais vite mais ça s'entend des fois
de la pâte intelligent vous avez beau
changer les visages si ça reste du
baratin ça reste du baratin et les gens
votent pas pour vous et pourquoi la
gauche perd aujourd'hui parce que ces
électeurs traditionnels restent à la
maison et c'est pas tant qu'il vote
autre chose il reste à la maison parce
qu'ils sont des résultats et moi
j'assume de dire je le reproche
d'ailleurs de nommer les choses je les
nomme ils sont déçus ce qui veut pas
dire tout est mauvais mais en tout cas
ils sont suffisamment déçus pour rester
à la maison et parfois même ils ont
l'impression qu'on n'est pas tout à fait
notre place et moi je crois que débat
politique il a besoin de de clarté
d'avoir une droite de droite il sera
droite extrême droite et une gauche à
gauche or là aujourd'hui il y a une
forme de dérèglement des fous dans le
paysage politique français vous avez une
gauche qui s'aventure parfois à droite
une droite qui donne le sentiment
parfois de se sentir bien à l'extrême
droite et l'extrême droite qui défend la
retraite à 60 ans
si vous souvenez les vos grands-parents
mais quand il réglait la mire du
téléviseur mais c'est ça c'est qu'il y a
un problème de mis on se dit mais on a
l'impression nos électeurs les gens ne
sont pas au bon endroit alors il y en a
qui vous disent c'est la modernité que
de bouger non c'est pas la modernité
c'est on n'est pas au bon endroit dans
les Yvelines comme au niveau national ce
discours là un discours non pas clivant
mais clair c'est pas parce qu'on est
beaucoup plus
décomplexé en termes de valeur principe
et de solutions qui doit être assumée en
tout cas c'est ce que je souhaite par la
gauche départementale et ça doit passer
aussi par de nouvelles générations ça
commence on a on est aux municipal de
nouveaux visages moi je je parie sur ces
nouveaux visages
sont nombreux au Mureaux à Chanteloup et
sur des valeurs claires prendre les
valeurs claires un exemple par exemple
la défense de la culture à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a eu des
choix qui ont été faits parce qu'il faut
faire des économies là encore sur
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin il y a
eu des coupes budgétaires sur l'aspect
culture on va préciser que c'est pas une
compétence obligatoire non plus de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
qui a décidé de faire des économies sur
ces différents postes il y a un
collectif qui s'est qui s'est monté avec
beaucoup des luttes gauche voir tous les
élus de gauche du territoire pour
défendre cette culture ça c'est une
valeur de gauche à défendre je vais
emprunter à une chronique ce matin
de François Morel sur France Inter
pendant le cité une radio concurrente
mais il cité Churchill et je trouve ce
je m'a rappelé cette citation que je
connaissais mais j'avais oublié
churchilla on disait on demandait de
couper dans le budget de la culture pour
financer l'effort de guerre et il a
répondu quoi mais alors pourquoi nous
battons nous
il avait réclamé du sang et des larmes
il avait annoncé qu'il aurait du sang et
des larmes au britanniques mais
il a au moment où on lui demande de
couper le budget de la culture pour
financer l'effort de guerre cette phrase
là et aujourd'hui à Saint-Quentin la
Meuse grognassel la ferme de belva le
scarabée tous ces équipements toutes ces
associations se voient privées de
dizaines de milliers d'euros un tiers de
leur subvention parce que
l'agglomération fait le choix de couper
dans ses dépenses là on a aussi aux
communes de venir compenser comme une
Vienne
et pas des agglomérations heureusement
pour la scène nationale parce que c'est
une compétence et pour le prisme et
l'encours donc Montigny et Élancourt ont
les moyens préservés je m'en réjouis
mais là où sont les accords
on a des engagements pris pour les
saisons à venir
à la Meuse
à la ferme de Bel et bain comment on
fait on dénon les contrats non
évidemment on va pas le faire donc on a
été chercher des moyens supplémentaires
et on va les trouver sans doute pour
compenser cela mais c'est un choix
politique
cette attitude qui consiste de la part
de
l'agglo passer le ballon de rugby à
d'autres en disant c'est pas ma faute
c'est l'autre bon la réalité c'est que
on a eu le avec les événements du début
de l'année les grandes manifestations
pour la République un désir profond de
se réunir de vivre ensemble et justement
quand est-ce qu'on se retrouve sinon par
la culture en Inde des territoires les
plus créatifs les plus innovants qui
soit sur le plan culturel on est en
train de sacrifier cela et bien ça va
avoir de l'impact ça va avoir des
conséquences savoir y compris des
conséquences en termes de vivre ensemble
dans l'agressivité dans
des des personnes c'est c'est évident
c'est le choix politique fait par la
majorité de droite aujourd'hui de
l'agglomération je le regrette nous le
combattrons et nous serons aux côtés des
acteurs culturels pour éviter cette case
parce que je sais qu'une véritable casse
de des équipements culturels et des
associations culturelles sur le
territoire un dernier mot ça concerne la
ville de Trappes la ville de Trappes qui
a connu un drame il y a un peu plus d'un
mois la mort d'un jeune de 14 ans en bas
de son immeuble trois semaines plus tard
c'est une femme enceinte qui recevait
une balle dans le dos à rentrer tout
simplement chez elle un climat
particulier sur cette ville de Trappes
est-ce que la situation est sous
contrôle attrape aujourd'hui vous qui
était lui dans cette commune
de 14 ans qui meurt par un tir de
pistolet mitrailleur
où ça comptait un autre Daouda Kanouté
trois autres qui auraient pu aussi
mourir et
l'enquête se poursuit donc là-dessus
j'ai par définition pas d'information
puis ensuite une femme enceinte à terme
d'ailleurs qui reçoit une balle cette
fois-ci petit calibre je pense que
d'ailleurs les affaires n'ont rien à
voir dans les deux cas c'est tragique et
pourtant à côté de ça depuis que Trap
est en zone de sécurité prioritaire on a
20% en moins de délinquance en matière
délinquance économique d'agression faite
aux personnes
de trafic de stupéfiants bref on a une
recule des fêtes délinquance mais des
actes qui sont des actes graves un
meurtre en l'occurrence sur la voie
publique d'un enfant donc il y a une
situation préoccupante et ça veut dire
qu'il faut maintenir les forges on est
parlé avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard Cazeneuve qui est parfaitement
conscient de cela qui a réuni d'ailleurs
il y a peu de temps des acteurs de la
sécurité sur ces questions et notamment
pour trap et notamment les responsables
de l'État qui sont en charge de ces
questions là
moi c'est un vrai sujet de préoccupation
et en même temps je me dois dire que
fort heureusement trap c'est pas ça et
la Marche Blanche la montrait
on refuse la banalisation de la violence
attrape on refuse aujourd'hui personne
ne va l'accepter il y a cette
mobilisation
mais quand vous aujourd'hui vous écoutez
le commentaire qui était fait c'est
comme si à Trappes tous les jours il se
passait des événements
d'une gravité absolue et comme si la
population finalement c'était accoutumé
à cette violence là c'est ce qui c'est
une violence exceptionnelle j'ai bien
exceptionnelle et qui dure depuis
plusieurs mois il y avait eu des coups
de feu avant cette assassinat du jeune
summertre des coups de feu qui avaient
été entendus dans certains quartiers de
la ville par exemple voilà on va faire
les récits de je dis pas que c'est une
ville calme trap mais trap c'est pas
c'est pas ça c'est ça vous avez compris
ces difficultés sauf qu'on parle que de
travailler qui sont mis en place pardon
de le dire si j'écoute ce qu'on dit de
trap on ne parle que de ça on dit pas de
Trappes c'est une des villes qui
aujourd'hui et je parle pas des aspects
culturels mais à produire de parmi deux
des plus brillants universitaires en
termes de recherche sur la question de
l'islam Ahmed Boubeker et Rachid benzine
qui sont des des universitaires et
chercheurs connus qui travaillent au
plus haut niveau et qui
sont des références à ce qu'on parle de
non on a évidemment des immenses
artistes on a des chefs d'entreprise et
c'est une raison pour lesquelles attrape
on est en train de d'organiser en lien
avec un certain nombre d'élus je pense
notamment l'adjoint au maire de Guy
Malanda l'irabé qui avait pris cette
initiative un réseau ce qu'on appelle
les aliments vous savez c'est les
anciens se faisait dans les grandes
écoles les anciennes trappes parce qu'on
a aujourd'hui
fraîcheur des chefs d'entreprise des
ingénieurs partout est-ce qu'il nous
facilitera je l'espère en construisant
ce réseau et bien l'obtention de stage
d'un apprentissage ici d'un stage en
alternance voilà on va essayer de
travailler aussi diversifier les moyens
de valoriser ce que sont les richesses
de cette commune mais il y a pas de
trappe dans la circonscription et
l'oncle on y fait aussi des choses
formidables et dans bien d'autres
communes de l'agglomération et de ma
circonscription donc à La Verrière aussi
il y a j'étais avec Amel el Moussaoui
champion de l'Union européenne Union
européenne et bientôt j'espère champion
d'Europe
en poids Walter voilà des formidables
exemples parce que sont des gens qui
nous rendent fier de d'appartenir et de
vivre dans ce territoire merci Benoît
Hamon Merci à VOUS prochain café
politique le 12 juin un autre élu
viendra s'installer ici pour parler de
son parcours et des dossiers qui le
préoccupent je vous retrouve d'ici là à
chaque soir du lundi au vendredi pour le
journal de la rédaction